welcome back we're not going to talk
about some important questions that
arise when you use uh regression in in
real problems
so
well is at least one of the predictors
useful in predicting the response right
that's sort of the first order question
is the the predictors on the whole have
anything anything to say about the
outcome
if not we probably want to stop there
but
given that there is some effect overall
which of the predictors are important
are they all important or only some
subset
how well does the model fit the data
and also given a set of predictive
values what responsive value should we
predict so what's our prediction
of sales given
a certain level of of advertising in the
three modes and how accurate is that
prediction so these are all things we
can answer from the model
well
these one two and four three we'll
examine by looking at some alternative
models
so
to answer the first question is at least
one predictor useful is the model
overall have any predictive value
we we do
we we look at the drop in training error
so this is the total sum of squares
remember if we just use the mean to
predict that's that's the no predictor
model
this is the the residual sum of squares
achieved using all three predictors
and
we can look at the drop the percent
variance explained
which actually i've got here for for
that
we defined this earlier now it's 0.897
so it was about 0.6 something before
now by adding the two more predictors
we've increased that to 0.897 so this
says that we reduce the variance of
sales around this mean
by almost 90
by using these three predictors that
seems pretty impressive
to
quantify that in a more statistical way
we can form
the f ratio which is defined as follows
it's the drop in training error
divided by p
p is the number of parameters we fit
here it's three right the three kinds of
advertising budgets
divided by the mean squared residual so
n is the sample size and we subtract off
the number of parameters we fit which is
p
plus one for the intercept
so statistical theory tells us that we
can compute the statistic and under the
null hypothesis that there's no effect
of any of the predictors
this will have a
an f distribution with p and n minus p
minus 1 degrees of freedom
and again there are tables of this or
your computer program will compute this
for you
the f-statistic here is huge
and it's p-value
i haven't recorded here but it's less
than .0001
so this says what we kind of believe
already looking at the
at the previous tables and the graphs
that there's a strong effect here of the
predictors on the outcome they certainly
have something to say about the
the outcome
okay
when we fit linear regression models one
of the things we have to do is decide on
what are the important variables to
include in the model by the way
this is not rob anymore
rob asked me to do this section because
a little hard for him
get in
so
the most direct approach is called all
subsets or best subsets regression so
basically what you're going to do
is you're going to compute the least
squares fit for all the possible subsets
of the variables and then choose between
them based on some criterion
that balances
the training error of the model size
now this might seem like a reasonable
thing to do
if you have a small number of variables
but it gets really hard when the number
of variables gets large
so if you've got p variables there's 2
to the p subsets
and you know that 2 to the p grows
exponentially with the number of
variables so for example when p is 40
they're over a billion models
right so we're talking about subsets
like a model might have variable 1 3 and
5 in it that's a subset of size three
and then a another model might have a
subset of size four
and uh
with 40 variables there's over a billion
such models so that clearly becomes
cumbersome
searching through such a big model space
and so what we need instead is an
automated approach that searches through
for us that finds a subset of them
and so we'll describe uh two commonly
used approaches next
forward selection is a very attractive
approach
because it's both tractable
and it gives a good sequence of models
so this is how it works
you start with a null model and the null
model has no predictors in it but it
will just have the intercept in it
and the intercept is the mean of y
with no other variables in the model
and now what you do is you add variables
one at a time so
the first variable you add you do it as
follows you fit p simple linear
regression models
each with one of the variables in and
the intercept
and you look at each of them
and you add to the null model the
variable that results in the lowest
residual sum of squares so basically you
just search through all the single
variable models and pick the best one
now i haven't picked that you fixed that
variable in the model and now you search
through the remaining p minus one
variables again
and
find out which variable should be added
to the variable you've already picked to
best improve the residual sum of squares
and you continue in this very in this
fashion add in one variable at a time
and until some stopping rule is
satisfied for example in all the
remaining variables have a
p value above some threshold
now this sounds like it might be
computationally quite difficult as well
but it turns out it's not there's some
there's some clever tricks you can use
to to do all these evaluations um very
efficiently
so in a similar fashion and and this is
if if p is not too large you can start
from the other end
so you start with a model with all the
variables in the model
and now you're going to remove them one
at a time
and this time you're going to remove
each at each step you're going to remove
the variable that does the least damage
to the model in other words you want to
remove a variable that's got the least
significance
and that you can actually find from
looking at the the t statistics for each
of the
variables
and and remove the one with the least
significant t statistic
and now you've got a a model with p
minus one variables and you just repeat
and you keep on going in that fashion
again until you reach
some threshold that you've defined
perhaps in in terms of a
p-value
so these are two approaches they might
seem somewhat ad hoc but they're very
effective and later we'll discuss more
systematic criteria for choosing an
optimal member in the path of models
produced by the either forward or
stepwise model selection
some of these criteria include something
known as mallow cp
akaiki information criterion
aic
that's the abbreviation and then bic
which is bayesian information criterion
these all sound like very important
methods they're named after important
people and they're very popular and and
then there's something called adjusted r
squared
and one of our favorites is cross
validation which you'll be learning
about
we'll talk more about model selection in
in
in the later
in later sessions
now there's some other considerations in
regression models
that we haven't really touched on yet
and the one is qualitative predictors
so some some variables are not
quantitative but qualitative in other
words they don't take values on a
continuous scale but they take values in
in a discrete set
so we call them categorical predictors
or factor variables
um
we're going to see a
matrix
um of
data in the next slide
it's a credit card data in fact i'll
just take you there now
and so here's a bunch of variables
um
on on credit cards and and ratings and
we see
the the current balance on the credit
card the age number of cards and so on
these are all quantitative variables
now in addition to these variables
we have
we have some qualitative variables so
one of them is gender so that takes on
values male and female
student so the student status of the of
the card holder whether they're a
student or not so these are qualitative
values
marital status
say married single or divorced there's
no order really in those those variables
they're just different categories
and likewise ethnicity say caucasian
african-american or asian again not
in no way an ordered variable
so how do we deal with such qualitative
predictors when we fit in linear
regression models
so
let's
let's consider our example on on credit
cards again imagine and investigating
the difference in credit card balance
between males and females
ignoring the other variables
so what we do is we create a new
variable
um let's call it
x i
and it's going to
well x we call it x and the i value is
going to be one if the eighth person is
a female and a zero if the i
person is a male
so we got a a name for such a variable
we call it a dummy variable it's a
created variable just to represent this
categorical
feature
okay so for each value of i we score
an individual as 0 1 depending if they
female
male or female
and so now if we put such a variable in
a model
let's say on its own
we've got
the linear regression model with the
coefficient for this dummy variable
x i
and let's see what it it produces well
since x i takes on only two possible
values zero or one
the model is either going to be beta0
plus beta1 plus error
if the person is female
and if the person is male it's just
going to be beta0 plus error
so beta1 is is telling us
the effect of being female versus the
baseline in this case of being male
and so that's how we deal with the
categorical variable
with just two levels
so here we see the results of the
regression model using just the single
variable gender and the dummy variable
0 1 that the one representing female
and and so we see the result and
the coefficient's 19.73
but it's not significant the p value is
0.66 which is not significant
so
contrary to popular wisdom
females don't generally have a higher
credit card
balance than males
the number is 19.73 slightly higher but
it's not significant
so what do we do if you have a variable
with more than two levels
so ethnicity is such a variable
well we just make more dummy variables
so ethnicity takes has three levels
so we'll make two dummy variables in
this case and we'll call them x1 and x2
and so x one is the the value for the i
individual for very dummy variable one
we'll call it one if the person's eighth
person's asian otherwise zero
and the second dummy variable will be
one if the eighth person is caucasian
and zero if not
and of course if they both zero the
person the individual will be
african-american
and so
that's the general rule if you've got a
categorical variable
with three levels you make two dummy
variables if it's got two levels you
make one dummy variable and if it's got
k levels you'll make k minus one dummy
variables to represent each of those
categories
so what does the model look like in this
case
well we'll have a model now with two
coefficients one for each of these dummy
variables
and let's look at the different cases so
if the person's asian
they'll get the beta 1
if the person's
caucasian they'll get the beta 2
and if the person's african-american
they don't have beta 1 or beta2 so the
baseline beta0 represents such a an
individual
and so what we see now is that beta1
represents the difference between
the baseline beta0 which is
african-american and and the difference
between that individual and an asian so
it's the additional effect being
for being an asian and beta-2 is the
additional effect for being caucasian
and as i said there will be always one
fewer dummy variable than the number of
levels
so in this case we call
the the category african-american is
known as the baseline level because it
doesn't have a parameter representing it
except beta0
so here's the linear model we've picked
african-american as a baseline and so
that actually determines which
comparisons we make so the coefficient
minus 18.69 is comparing
asian
to african-american and that's not
significant and likewise
the caucasian to african-american which
is also not significant
now it turns out the choice of the
baseline does not affect the fit of the
model the residual sum of
sum of squares would be the same no
matter which
category you chose as the baseline
but the contrasts
would change because that would deter
the pick in the baseline determines
which contrasts you make and so the p
values potentially will change as you
change the baseline